getting us here is a triangle with three
unknown side lengths but according to
the triangle inequality theorem any two
sides when you add them together they're
going to be longer than the third side
and the way to kind of visualize this
just to show you an overview is say for
example this is one of the sides and
here's the other two sides if these
other two sides don't add up to more
than the third side you can see they're
not going to be a triangle here even if
you rotate these sides down like this
they're not going to be able to reach to
span that distance of that third side so
the only way you're gonna have a
triangle is if you these two sides are
actually when you add them up they're
longer than the third side okay so using
that we're gonna go ahead and make three
inequalities and we're going to solve
them so the first inequality is 2x plus
1 plus 3x minus 4 is greater than X plus
7 so these two sides added together have
to be more than this third side so if we
do that we get 5x minus 3 is greater
than X plus 7 if we subtract X from both
sides we get 4x if we add 3 to both
sides we get 10 and if we divide by 4 we
get X is greater than 10 force which is
5 halves okay now let's go ahead and use
these two sides they have to be greater
than that third side so we have 3x minus
4 plus X plus 7 has to be greater than
2x plus 1 so this gives us 4x plus 3 is
greater than 2x plus 1 if we subtract 2x
from both sides we get 2x if we subtract
3 from both sides we get let's see
negative 2 and if we divide by 2 X has
to be greater than negative 1 okay and
then the last one is let's see we've
done these two we've got these two are
greater than this one here so we've got
2x plus 1 plus X plus 7 has to be
greater than 3x minus 4 okay so here we
get 3x plus 8 is greater than 3x minus 4
and if we subtract 3x from both sides we
get 8 is greater than negative 4 which
is always true so we don't have to worry
about that inequality so we're just
looking at these two here now if we
graph these on the number line let's see
here's negative 1 here's 5 halves right
so if you're greater than 5 halves okay
and you're also greater than negative
one now when you think of the word and
it has to satisfy both of these
requirements right it has to be greater
than five halves and greater than
negative one in math you know an means
the intersection it means the overlap of
the two sets so where do they overlap
they overlap right here as long as
you're greater than five halves
you will also be greater than negative
one but just because you're greater than
negative one doesn't mean that you're
going to satisfy the requirement of
being greater than five halves so we
look at where the overlap or intersect
and you can see that as long as X is
greater than five halves then we're
going to be able to form a triangle with
these three sides so I hope this helped
you understand how to work with the
triangle inequality theorem better
subscribe to the channel check out more
math videos on Mario's math tutoring
YouTube channel and I look forward to
seeing in the future videos I'll talk to
you soon